and a lot of people have been tagging us
in this after mosh didn't Kutcher just
got his brown belt a big deal from Hagen
[ __ ] oh there's no let's just of a
picture yep nine years
interesting video though huh good trend
good training how long's I get my Brahma
brother I don't know dude you keep
training with him and all his calls
calls calls calls calls calls what belt
are you on now oh I'm a pencil blue belt
yeah I don't consider that anymore
I gotta get it I got to start all over
yet how longs it take to get a blue the
average the average person yeah that's
how much you train pray three to four
years damn I didn't know I think demi
lovato is a blue belt too you can only
village it place right where's it go
blue blue purple brown black right
alrighty
yeah if you're not a Silurian - you'll
love Brandon Brandon what
I got my black pot yesterday that's
really thank you what else all right
this is from last week but John I mean
you didn't get your black belt for ever
yeah I'm trained every day
professionally for hours yeah yeah wait
what's that have to do your point to you
like you're you're a tenor are here on
school and you get a black belt you
earned it
why would I got my black belt from a
mall Easton yeah if I was stayed there I
probably got my black belt ask me to
come back a while ago - you got it you
got it quickly though how long have you
been you've had you've been trained to
not get it quickly how long have you
been training eight years oh okay every
day every day easy on there yeah yeah I
don't know is that long yeah that's a
long time yeah eight years yeah every
day - again your celebrity blue bells
purple belts brown belt it's just a
different path different path yeah if
you're competitive with it yeah it's
gonna I mean wouldn't they know - like
especially if let's just say Demi
Lovato's belt isn't legitimately a blue
belt wouldn't she roll with other blue
belts just regular blue it's nice but
they wouldn't put her in yet what
happens in those school is that if
you're rolling with Demi Lovato also
it's not you know your Demi Lovato yeah
yeah but also who she had a blue belt in
there I don't know it's the same place
Wiz Khalifa and uh Glaser yeah I see
Brandon's face yeah she's not you know
she's not like that is a celebrity
gender you know like Madonna hair you
know yeah I noticed that like certain
schools like when you're a blue belt if
you're a purple belt on their hands Oh
in comparison to other schools like it
was such it was such a difference it was
like [ __ ] light-years different
light-years but who knows how hard did
you know Lovato she might be training
all the time we don't know how much
she's training - I don't know she might
be legit yeah when I go on TRT and I'm
training every [ __ ] day good luck
guys are you really gonna do it
no I'm shooting a TV show I have a
podcast two children and I just stand up
so it's very difficult to find time
literally just like practice on my only
say no CRT CRT have you not gonna do
wrong I don't know I was talking to
Brendan about I don't feel like I need
it my dick can still cut a diamond and I
have a lot of energy I just don't want
to [ __ ] with that but you want to get
bigger right not really
I saw her
get more veiny I that though did for me
to do that would be a little bit look
just I'm am Who I am
skinny guy you're not skinny though no I
could put on five more pounds maybe look
more muscular awesome alright
for how long tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]